what's up guys it's Justine and today
we're going to be doing a water proof
test of the new Samsung s9 and before we
get into that I just want to preface
this with thing I don't know how to swim
which is also problematic I don't really
like going underwater so doing this
video it's gonna be really difficult for
me and I'm sure you guys are gonna make
fun of me but that's okay I'm sure I've
heard worse but this is the new s9 I did
an unboxing video and I'll be doing a
review video of a camera comparison
between this and the iPhone 10 PS 9 is
IP 68 rated so it is water resistant up
to 5 feet which hopefully we won't go
any further than that dust and fan
resistant and since we're in Hawaii it
is getting a test of all of those things
as we speak how's it look Jen take a
look
it's a look got a phone let's get it all
set up here do you think it's gonna
recognize me you know I don't know oh it
did so that's just your look I'm not
sure maybe this is what I look like with
our pole cleaning here we're just gonna
we're gonna let him go and do this thing
alright you ready no nope already the
underwater test is about to come
gonna be so not even that exciting
I predict the fetid Swiffer okay I told
you let's see what happens ready
[Music]
pretty well think so camera it's
functional phones working I'm still
alive so we're gonna try out the super
slow-mo and it's interesting because
with this there is a little box on the
screen and whenever some action or
movement happens inside of that screen
that's when the Samsung besides this is
what we want to get slo-mo so you're
gonna hit this button
[Music]
now jump out the back camera I have it
set to UHD and we're gonna do some
underwater tests with that and see what
it looks like
you ready Jen yeah I don't have to get
in whoo I'm having fun get that GoPro
ready
[Music]
Bixby come on Vick speed Bixby Bixby
it's like Bixby I'm not I don't need you
a ball thank you guys so much for
watching I actually had a lot of fun
testing this out so I'm looking forward
to checking out all the footage I hope
you guys enjoy it as well I am currently
working on an S 9 verse an iPhone 10
video so look for that very very soon
you guys want to subscribe feel free to
do that below and I will see you in my
next video
[Music]